is
yeah you know what i mean like
are you ready
we all know
um
you were here
um
so i was gonna do that
uh
okay
hey
anyway
i'm
great
this
all right
organizations
um
a minute
okay let me call you back
uh
[ __ ]
[Music]
we have lots of your colleagues out here
so they're worth it
as long as these are on friday there's
going to be a large number because they
don't have anything else to do
okay
we'll make it work
happy to rotate
thank you
uh
new conspiracy theories muslim foreign
no
because the quarterbacks today are still
good
receivers
um
is
[Music]
[Music]
okay
good morning good morning good morning
we've had a couple of days
of uh electing our chairs
yesterday we approved 18 chairs
and was pretty exciting for us uh we had
three contested races
and uh that included congresswoman rosa
delorme now chair of the appropriations
committee
following in the footsteps of the first
woman to serve in that capacity anita
lowey
paving the way all three candidates were
women for chair of appropriations
the chair of the foreign affairs
committee greg meeks
of new york he at the sa rosa is of
connecticut
greg meeks of of new york following the
sepsis of another new yorker
uh elliott engel and uh the chair of the
ag committee
uh david scott
from georgia the first african american
ever chosen to be the chair of the
agriculture committee
pretty exciting following the footsteps
the great leadership of colin peterson
greg meek's also
african-american so it was pretty
historic the woman in two
african-americans in the contested races
but throughout our
our leadership half the rooftop or
either women
or people of color in the chairs of the
committee
there are more chairs to be announced
but these were the ones that related
to um rules and budget related to the
syrian policy committee so those were
two of the speaker's announcements that
i made there are others that will follow
but as i said to the members then
the gavels we held the house will hold
the gavels
132 of them starting with the 18 that
were chosen yesterday but
i'm excited about it because when they
made their presentations over the
several days this week it was a
demonstration of
values of knowledge of commitment to
america's working
families in every one of our committees
and the beautiful diversity of those
committees as well so
it was a cause uh for celebration
as you know we are in the uh let me do
this right
we are oh well it hurts but we'll may
stay up
we are in the lame duck session uh we
have
important work to do here of uh we've
spent a good deal first part of lame
duck
on the national defense of authorization
and legislation i want to salute
our chairman adam adam smith and mr
thornberry the ranking member
for the great bipartisan legislation
they put together
it's uh this is the national security
the oath we take to protect and defend
our constitution our country and i'm
very very proud
of the work that went into it and now
uh will come to the floor uh next week
uh
our leader mr hoyer will be talking
about scheduling there but
i want to uh reference some of what adam
smith and
max thornberry said about the bill and
in their statement on the conference
report among the provisions we are most
proud of
and i we joined them in this the
authorization of hazardous duty pay for
our servicemen
and women and members in harm's way
improvements in military housing and
programs for military families and
children
with special needs the quality of life
for our military families is very
essential to our national security
addressing the shortest of military
child care
authorizing 8.4 billion dollars in
military construction process
to fortify critical infrastructure and
base realignment and closure
cleanup very essential important new
tools to deter
china and russia reforms to make the
pentagon more efficient
innovative and cost effective
significant bipartisan provisions
on artificial intelligence and cyber
security
and provisions that strengthen our
alliance with israel i
especially want to acknowledge how
pleased we are
uh with the leadership also of
congressman anthony brown a member of
the committee a veteran
of our services uh
a decorated member of the military who
now serves in the house
anthony brown uh we provided long-term
uh we included the process of changing
the names
of military bases purposefully
purposefully named for white
supremacists
how could that have been they just
decided to name the basis for white
supremacists
i'm so happy personally because i have
four brothers who served in the army and
they served on many of those bases
around the country and we would always
just say
why why is that now it isn't um
but it also provides long overdue
benefits to veterinary
veteran area veterans who were
impacted by agent orange this was really
important
to many of us this issue was long
overdue when we passed it now it needed
to be improved and they do so
on the bill and again the on debate get
back to the basis it reflects our
highest
ideals as americans we urge the
president
to sign the nda which has been passed on
a bipartisan
basis for 59 years this would be 60.
so again this was this is very
um shall we say intensive in terms of
the attention
it requires our members were constantly
working on it and that's why i wanted to
take the time
to take the pride in this legislation
as you know we are engaged in the talks
on the
omnibus bill when i spoke to seth
leader mcconnell yesterday we talked
about the possibility
of putting a covet package on the
omnibus bill
but he and i being appropriators know
that if you're going to do that
you have to have an omnibus bill and so
we have to work through
the um all of the uh
provisions that are still unresolved
there were making progress
congress of madame chair anita lowey and
chair shell bridge or shelby on the
senate side
have come to great agreement on the 302
b's that's
more more um appropriations talk but
and and how they would proceed they've
made great progress
more needs to be done and at the same
time simultaneous with that
we're working on the covet package and
on wednesday was our deadliest day every
day that anyone dies
is a complete tragedy for our country 2
800
americans lost
we believe that one of the saddest parts
of it is the neglect
that this administration has paid delay
denial distortion hoax
and now finally
we have a new dynamic a new president
in a little more than a month committed
to crushing the virus
a new dynamic a vaccine a successful
vaccine more than one successful vaccine
to make all the difference in the world
that is imminent till the inauguration
and the
emergence of the vaccine which will be
soon but not for everyone just because
of
the the quantity needed and the money
needed to
to go from vaccine from the lab to
vaccination
to the arm and that is going to require
more than we're talking about now
but what joe biden has been talking
about
we believe that um humor leader schumer
and i believe that the framework
the bipartisan framework unveiled
by the senators in bipartisan way with
the support of house members
josh gottheimer in the house from our
side um
on both sides of the aisle could be the
basis for real
bicameral negotiations we it's not text
yet it's a framework
so as they work on the text we hope
it'll take us very close
to something we can put into the into
the
uh omnibus which is at the same time
being
um president biden has said
that this package would be just
at best just a start
and that's how we see it as well it's
less money
but over a shorter period of time and we
need to do it to save lives and
livelihood with the hope
that much more help is on the way
the uh again we will this vaccine has
had such high 95 percent
was a the pfizer vaccine and a
madeira vaccine give us great help
but again we have to have the resources
to to exercise our options that we have
to buy the vaccine
would hope that the president would
immediately
exercise the call upon the defense
production act
to produce the vaccine that's what is
going to require to have the amount that
we need
and then to have the logistics
the money there for the states uh to and
that
further highlights the need for funding
for state and local government
because we can pay for the vaccine we
can pay for its delivery
but it's administ administration of it
by healthcare professionals and others
still it needs to be funded as well so
that's good news from that
help is on the way from joe biden who
sees
the need we had
some not so good news on the job front
that further necessitates
our taking action to crush the virus to
open up the economy to open up our
schools
but in order to do it so we must do so
safely scientific science based
in our approach on all of it you
probably did see
the jobs report this morning which is
indicative
is indicative of uh further indicative
of the need for us to have
crush the virus so the economy can get
going so all of that is to come to this
place to say
there is momentum there is momentum
uh with the action that the senators and
house members in a bipartisan way have
taken with them
it could provide meaning relief for
millions who are suffering
economically personally health-wise and
so i'm pleased that uh
the tone of our conversations is one
that
uh is indicative of the decision
to get the job done i'll take any
questions you may have
thank you speaker speaker
thank you so much
what you said about momentum
realistically how soon
do you and leader mcconnell need to cut
a deal
in order to have a package to vote on
before the holidays
but we will have we have the time to do
it it doesn't
it and again
we won't have it on the omnibus we have
to have an omnibus
and we're hoping that that will
accelerate the discussions on the
omnibus
we are going to keep government open you
know we're not going to have a
continuing resolution
but we need to take the time to do that
and then as i said we saw a framework
they're putting uh now they have to turn
it into text
and then so we'll take the time we need
and we must get it done and we must get
it done
by uh this before we leave we cannot
leave without it
does that mean we have about a week it
doesn't matter
we will take the time that we need and
the question is
um when will the text be ready so that
we can
combine it into the but the the
omnibus is not finished yet we have a
number of
what we call ash and trash it's a lot of
other issues that need to be resolved
and they're in the course of doing that
and i don't want to in any way
undermine the great bipartisan
negotiations that are going on
between the democrats and republicans
that senator shelby
as the chair of the appropriations
committee in the senate
anita lowey as the chair in the house
their staff's
working together so don't worry about
the date
it will be insufficient time for us to
to get it done the sooner the better but
not at the expense of the initiatives
that we need to address in the bills
thank you just to be clear you said no
continuing resolution
i don't want anything right i understand
that but if you are on the precipice of
getting a coronavirus
but what shifted in your opinion when
the problem solver caucus
had a much larger bill a few months ago
you did not like that piece of
legislation
what has shifted that when they're on
board with this piece that's come out of
the side
perhaps you missed what i said earlier
joe biden committed
to ending and crushing the virus and
having a build a better america
initiative
big old back letter a vaccine
answered to our prayers
an answer to our prayers of 95 percent
effectiveness
in terms of pfizer and modernity and
there may be others
uh coming forward now that makes
that is a total game changer
a new president and a vaccine
so there's nothing to do these are
different
what what was then before was not more
of this
this is has simplicity it's what we've
had in our bills
it's for a shorter period of time but
that's okay now
because we have a new president a
president who recognizes
that we need to depend on science to
stop
the virus a president who understand
that america's working families
need to have money in their pockets in a
way
that takes them into the future without
any of the contractions
of any of the other bills uh that the
administration was associating itself
with them before we feel very
excited about the prospect that the
there's a
bipartisan bill because i told members
i'm not bringing any more bills
that are not bipartisan we wanted to
to to um show what needs to be done
in the interest of negotiation they're
negotiating
it's a good product it's not everything
we want don't get me wrong i
i don't want the republicans to think
that we uh that this is a dream come
true it is not
but it is a path forward yeah
not to accept half of the loaf months
ago he said i'm not going to accept half
a
leg
don't characterize what we did before as
a mistake as a preface
to your question if you want an answer
that was not a mistake
it was a decision and it has taken us to
a place
where we can do the right thing without
other
shall we say considerations in the
legislation that we don't want
now that is it now the fact is
i'm very proud of where we are my chairs
my chairs have worked very hard on all
of this
they were not even happy with a a
proposal that we made
the other day before we saw this
proposal
they thought we had come back to too
small so
it's not about an indiv it's about how
we
address the needs of the american people
and we have to do it in a scientific way
and we have to do it in a way that
recognizes people need food
on the table they need to get their rent
paid they need money in their pockets
they need their unemployment insurance
to be there they do not need
a whole cacao of other things that are
on the agenda
that have nothing to do with meeting
their needs
so we're very pleased at where it is and
as i say
with a democratic president
committed to a scientific solution for
this
with the idea that we will have a
vaccine it's a complete game changer
from them
says that on his first day in office he
will use title ix to give transgender
students
access to sports bathrooms and locker
rooms in accordance with their gender
identity
and all federally funded schools does he
have the power to unilaterally do this
and do you agree with this
yes and i think he does this man speaker
pelosi
the petition that rita hart um is going
to file soon as far as her race is
concerned over in iowa
how is how is the house going to prevent
a
situation that was seen in 1985 between
mccloskey
um and and his republican opponent
and would you encourage uh the the loser
of the new york 22 race to do the same
thing
if their recount is in a very slim
origin
the issue relating to iowa is an issue
for the house administration
committee it's my understanding of that
the
uh rita hart an excellent candidate for
congress
has uh will be asking the house to take
this up but that
for further information about the
technicalities of that
that becomes that's a house not a
political but a house
administration matter house decides who
it will
seat we don't have any idea that new
york is a completely different
situation new york is a completely dis
different situation new york that there
could be 1500
5 000 votes not counted yet
so that is going into the court i think
monday is the day
in the court and that is uh
and that is what is um uh
we'll see what happens in the court and
that may end up in the congress i don't
know
but the court will decide which votes
will be counted but
that's like down to 12 votes it's
interesting
people should know everyone should know
his or her vote counts
six votes are what the spread is at the
moment
in uh iowa 12 votes
now this is on the basis of hundreds of
thousands of votes cast
of hundreds of thousands of votes cast
so it is
um it is one of those uh matters that
time will tell we'll see what the court
says
we'll see what the uh house
administration
options are and what they decide to do
as they go forward
i just want to get a clarification as it
relates to your conversations with with
uh leader mcconnell so is this now a
situation where we're expecting a
an omnibus and any sort of current
american relief to be
met in the one piece of legislation
that would be a hope because that is the
vehicle leading
leaving the station and that's probably
uh i was pleased that he wanted to to do
it that way because that's how we have
i thought would that's what we thought
would be the best way to do
the vehicles leaving the station all in
other words you see a bill come to the
floor you don't see the whole
underpinnings on the orchestration of
what it takes to get to a place so if
there's a vehicle
and we can add uh this language once we
see the
text uh that is what we would be doing
on both components to bring something to
the floor oh yeah yeah yeah
and that's what we're that's what we're
working on yes and because we would want
a big strong vote as we will have
getting back to our be
earlier on the national
defense bill we are very proud of the
bipartisanship
that has gone into that uh the
quality of life issues there for
military families
also the a system to change the names of
the bases that
were named for white supremacists in
some cases
by design named for former members of
the confederacy
well after the civil war so
again there are many things in there
about our
practical uh responsibility to protect
and defend
but also about our values for us that
was not a provision or an issue
it was an ethic it was a uh
it was a a value thank you all very much
um